i i need to tell you something tell you
something
something i i've known this for a while
for a while i didn't mean to hide it but
i i wasn't sure i wasn't sure i
and now i know the markiplier you all
know and love
is not real
it all started in 2012 this youtuber who
was
thriving he came out of nowhere
but i knew something was off he wasn't
real
the perfect facial features the giant
muscular arms and his deep soothing
voice
he seemed perfect
too perfect
i started animating him in 2013. i
thought maybe it would help me get
closer to him
however when i started animating him i
could never draw him right
his features just didn't seem natural
why do you think i made so many
iterations of him
because i could never get him right
but then he asked me if i could edit for
him and of course i said yes
the closer i could get to him the bigger
the chances i had to find out the truth
that's when things got really strange he
would send me corrupted
footage his schedule was inconsistent
videos sometimes were missing
audio things that could be completely
normal until i started decoding the data
i started making games
as a ploy a ruse a way
to distract him why do you think i made
that game for him
i couldn't risk him knowing i was on to
him that's why i started making games
who wants to make games for a living
with this distraction i learned how to
code in multiple languages
just so i could access the data within
the videos
and that's when i saw something i
wish i couldn't see
the truth of markiplier that
he is not real
but now it's too late for me
i'm complacent now he just
pays me too well to let go he has his
non-existing claws wrapped around my
proverbial soul
so torn with this indecision
the truth over the cash
but not all hope is lost it's all up to
you now
marcus rachel he
doesn't pay you the bags of money he
pays me clearly
which means that you still have a chance
you can still escape the madness
markiplier
he's not real no matter what he says
no matter what he makes you believe he's
not